[APPLAUSE]
INTERVIEWER: Good.
Hello.
Maybe you'd like to introduce
yourself and tell us
what led you to working at the
university a couple of years
ago.
SUKI KIM: Well, I was born
and raised in South Korea,
and I moved to
America in my teens.
And I do actually come from--
there's a personal history.
The Korean War did
separate my family,
and some members ended up
being taken to North Korea.
This is not that unusual.
It actually happened
to a lot of people.
They estimate like a
million plus families were
affected by that back in 1953.
And having grown up with
that separation and sorrow,
then I became an immigrant
to going to America
in my teens, where I didn't
speak a word of English.
So I think that that
really was a big issue.
And then I went to North
Korea by chance in 2002
for the first time.
And then I realized there was
this world that was basically
a wound, heartbreak
for Korean people
that is not being explained
in a way we can understand.
I kept going back in.
And there's no way you can go
find out about North Korea,
except seeing the
government's propaganda.
You will just never see it.
So what that meant was--
and I went five times
through a decade.
And what that
meant was you would
have to go undercover and be
really embedded there in a way.
So I found out about
the school, which was
run by Evangelical Christians.
So I ended up
posing as a teacher,
posing as an
Evangelical Christian.
INTERVIEWER: So
the university was
run by Evangelical
Christians who
were sort of undercover
in the country,
and you were an
undercover teacher, just
layers of undercover.
SUKI KIM: Well, it's a
very complicated situation
to try to explain, obviously.
Because this group of
fundamental Evangelical
Christians that fund
the school-- $35 million
to build and a lot
more to operate--
they have made a deal, some
sort of an official deal,
to not proselytize.
They'll go there and build the
school-- because proselytizing
is an execution of a crime.
And we have seen that, where
people get detained there.
But those are different.
The ones who get
detained are the ones
who went in there
under tourist visa.
These are the people who go to
North Korea on a tourist visa
and take videos and
put it on YouTube.
There's a lot of actually these.
You just pay money, and
you can go as a tourist.
It's not a big deal to go
to North Korea that way.
But then they're
passing bibles out.
So those people will be
detained, no question about it.
But the group I was with
was working with the regime,
cooperating with the regime.
The whole deal was they're
going to basically fund
the education of the future
leaders of North Korea,
hoping one day they
will be converted.
A perfect population,
really, because it's actually
a very, very devoutly faithful
people to their cause--
I mean the great leader.
So when that great leader
falls, they will actually
convert to the next religion.
So they made that deal So
they are not-- the regime
knows exactly who they are.
They just do not proselytize.
So it's just not
out in the open.
So when I went in there
with them, I was, I guess,
posing as one of
them, but also they
were kind of posing as
not being Christians
when they were out in the open.
So it was a very
double situation.
INTERVIEWER: And this line, I
think what I got from the book
was that the students are
very apt at lying as well.
They're very good at lying, and
they lied to you constantly,
almost.
And so it just felt, with the
students lying and the teachers
lying and you lying, it just
felt like a lot of lies.
SUKI KIM: Truth and lies
was really a big theme.
It's interesting, because I just
gave a TED Talk in Vancouver.
And the theme of
this year was where
the Google founder
was, supposedly,
somewhere in the crowd.
But their big theme
was truth and lie,
and that's the talk I gave.
And it's because the whole
world is built on lies.
The entire system of the great
leader, this entire country
runs according to the
myth of the great leader.
And if that is a lie, then where
do you begin to know the truth?
And in order to
discover the truth,
I also had to pretend to be
something I'm not in order
to get to the truth.
So the question
of truth and lies
does become a really
important theme
when you do more and
more, I guess, research,
into the topic of North Korea.
INTERVIEWER: Cool.
And so who were the peoples
that you were teaching for--
SUKI KIM: It ended up being--
I didn't know this going in.
In 2011, which was
Juche year 100.
What that means is they
count the calendars.
Juche is North Korea's
foundational philosophy,
meaning self-reliance,
which is why
they're so isolated,
because they
don't rely on anybody else.
They also count
the calendar system
according to their original
great leader's birth,
so their calendar was different.
So 2011 was actually Juche year
100, although he died in 1994.
To celebrate his birthday,
despite the fact he died,
they shut down every
university across North Korea
and sent all the
university students
into construction fields to
build North Korea's biggest
idea, which is a powerful
and prosperous nation, which
is what they call themselves.
To build that, they sent all
the kids to construction fields,
except 270 young men, who
are the sons of the elite.
And those were the boys--
I mean, they're 19 and 20.
But those were the young
men I ended up living
with in this private location
where nobody was allowed out
of the premise.
INTERVIEWER: So what did
you discuss with them?
You were teaching them English.
It was a science
university, but you
weren't teaching them science.
And what was sort of the
day-to-day interactions
with them?
What would you--
SUKI KIM: No.
I mean, this just goes
back to the whole truth
and lies question.
It's a university of
science and technology,
but there were no
science teachers.
A lot of their
majors were computer,
but they didn't know the
existence of the internet.
So I did see people,
actually-- towards the end,
they showed me a student
with a Google page, actually,
and he was Googling something.
But when you talked to him
afterward, they didn't know.
They would ask questions
like, how many movies can you
watch on the internet?
And how long is a movie that
you see on the internet?
Like that kind of questions.
Clearly they're not
on the internet.
So this was sort of the daily
existence of that school.
Everything was watched 24/7.
Minders lived in the same
building as the teachers.
Counterparts were
people who oversaw
all the lesson plans because you
had to get everything approved.
Every class was recorded
and reported on.
I had meals three times
a day with the students,
and it's me and three
students at each table.
And that conversation
was reported on,
because they were
watching each other.
So they have these critique
meetings at least once a week,
where they then report
on what they've heard,
what they have witnessed.
So there wasn't a
single place you could
be where you had any privacy.
And I taught English.
That's the only subject that
got taught in that school.
But, basically, their
schedules were mapped out.
So they did tons and tons
of great leader duties
and great leader studies.
And then they learned English.
And it was just
repetition of that.
It was a soldier-like
existence for them.
INTERVIEWER: How much
of the outside world
could you discuss with them?
Did you try and sort of--
SUKI KIM: There were rules
and rules, as you can imagine.
The rules and rules
just went on and on.
And they just went from, you
know, you couldn't wear jeans,
because Kim Jong-il
really hated jeans,
because they were a symbol
of America, so not allowed
in that country.
But things like, do
not compare ever.
Like you wouldn't
say, oh, it's amazing.
It's like this, because
back home, in my country,
like, that's not allowed.
Don't ever suggest
there's anything
wrong with their
country was another one.
Never, ever discuss
the outside world.
Do not ever talk to
somebody outside when
you're taken on a trip outside,
which teachers were taken
on trips on weekend, just to
get groceries, or great leaders
buildings, because
every building is
about a great leader
in North Korea.
So there were all
these rules to follow,
so there was nothing you could
talk about the outside world.
But when you live with
someone for months and months
and months, and as a teacher,
where I could assign things,
with an approval that
I assigned letters.
I assigned essay writing
and compositions.
Through those things and also
daily conversation over meals,
things start slipping out
and escaping, and thoughts.
It was really more thoughts.
And the people asked me, did
you see North Koreans starving?
And I don't know
why people are so
curious about that,
because we know
there's an 80% food shortage.
I don't think that's
what was fascinating.
You know, yes, I was taken out
of Pyongyang on a school bus.
And you can guess those
things from looking
at the really, really
malnourished people out
in the distance.
They're not going to
let you talk to them,
but you can see that.
But I think it's more
what this kind of society
does to an individual
psychologically, I think,
is more what I was
there to find out,
which did become-- as we were
bonding, me and my students,
more and more, I think I did get
glimpses of their world more.
INTERVIEWER: I think
what surprised me
about reading the book
was how even the elite,
they fear the society, and
they play by the rules.
I think I'd assumed that those
nearly perhaps knew the game,
knew what was
going on, and would
be able to speak more freely.
But they weren't able to.
They--
SUKI KIM: I think it's amazing
how, in the rest of the world,
we get these reports
of North Koreans
are all sneaking DVDs
and watching soap operas,
and they're all
like on cell phones.
And that I didn't see.
Even if they did
not show that to me,
I didn't see how that
was going on so rampantly
in that country,
because what I saw
was such a tight control and
such a lack of knowledge.
Even if they saw some
forbidden video somewhere,
it's very clear to
me they just had
no concept of how--
for example, we all
had to-- in the Korean
culture, you make kimchi.
I don't know if you guys know
that that's a Korean dish
that every family eats.
And we make this massive
kimchi in November, and which
North Koreans do, too.
And we all peeled
garlics together.
But this was actually where
it was really complex,
because I felt like, that
age, 19-year-old college
students, boys,
to get all of them
to peel garlic so diligently
would be very hard in America.
I don't know about England.
But that would be
nearly impossible.
But they were so really
earnestly peeling garlic.
Because there, they said, if
we all make kimchi together,
it would be quicker.
So those were, I think, positive
moments of what I observed.
Even if that's obedience,
there was something
that was really heartwarming.
But at the same time,
they would ask me things
like-- we had this really
lovely moment where they then
began discussing.
Because it's a family
tradition in Korea.
Everybody makes kimchi
together in November.
And they said, you
know, their family
gets like 8 kilos of cabbages
delivered from the government.
And then depending on
the size of the family,
another family gets 12 kilos
of cabbages, government sends.
And he said to me-- actually
the group of them asked me.
They said, so what
about you, Professor?
How many kilos does
your government
send-- cabbages
do they send you?
And I was like, you know,
in Manhattan, [CHUCKLES]
where I live, no, the New
York City government is not
sending me cabbages to
make kimchi every November.
And I think it was moments like
that where I thought, you know,
this is not faking.
This is not a
government propaganda.
They really have no idea.
And there were a lot
of moments like that,
which does make you realize
the-- and these were
the best and brightest.
And so there were a lot of
moments like that where it just
was a different way.
And they were not
getting information
about the outside world.
INTERVIEWER: So the
campus that you were on
was-- I think one of things I
picked out that it was guarded
by female guards, which I
would have thoughts putting 19
and 20-year-old young man
with their female equivalents
would've been a
recipe for disaster.
But it didn't?
SUKI KIM: It didn't, actually.
I mean, as far as I know.
I didn't see them ever mixing.
And those women never
talked back to me.
I basically don't
really know what
the girls are like
in North Korea
because my only point of
reference were these boys.
And from what I understand,
what I understood,
because I was very curious
about that, that supposedly
the school-- why the schools
are allowed to be built
is really many, many reasons,
obviously, one of which
is government propaganda.
So that the foreign
media that can come in
for a couple of days and film
the school, and the school
looks fantastic,
and the kids look
really healthy and beautiful.
Then they can turn around
and say North Korea looks
like this, which it does not.
So when they did get
male soldiers there
to guard the place, I don't know
what they need guarding from
or to, because obviously
we're just not allowed out.
So I felt like it
was the guard's work
to make sure we did not escape.
Actually, they were
not protecting us.
I mean, it the other way around.
But they basically
didn't want men soldiers,
because they said it looked
too threatening, whereas women
soldiers are not threatening
to foreign eyes, supposedly.
So that was a reason.
And another reason nothing
happened between the boys
and the girls is because
there is such a class
difference in North Korea.
It's called songbun, and the
family difference, basically
the girls came from much
lower class than the boys,
and they just would not be
interested in each other.
They're not the kind of
people who mix in that world.
So that's what I
understood it to be.
INTERVIEWER: And what
was your relationship
like with the minders,
those who were sort
of watching over what you did?
And as an extension,
how much did you
feel watched, your emails,
your phone calls and so forth?
SUKI KIM: Well, you just--
you know, being in North Korea
is just a constant surveillance.
So I don't know if
there was a camera.
I definitely it was
tapped because they
would know the conversations.
Or the minders, we were told
there are-- the teachers
had email and internet.
The students didn't
even know what it was.
So even though our dorms were
right next to each other,
we were in a different
world, really.
And our emails, the
teachers' emails,
we were told by the
administrators of the school
who were running the school,
told us to basically set up
a different email when
you go into North Korea,
because they can really
easily go into your accounts
and stuff.
And you don't really want them
to have all of your friends
emails, too. [CHUCKLES] I
feel like my friends would
have all disowned me if
their privacy was jeopardized
like that.
So in these emails
that you sent home,
we were told to just
keep it minimum so
that people know you're safe.
But the minders knew it
was a monitored connection.
So I would say, for example,
I woke up today at 4:00 AM,
whatever.
And then the minder
would repeat that to me.
He would say, oh, so did you
get up at 4:00 AM this morning?
You must be tired.
So that does just wipe
out any sense of that--
and another thing
I realized there.
You know, they do have
letters in North Korea,
for example, letter
system, postal system.
But when I talked
to my students,
they didn't really
know what letters were.
They didn't know
how to write it.
They didn't really send them.
And I realized these
communication methods,
we need privacy.
Letters do lose meaning.
Emails do lose meaning when
everybody else can see it.
Or it's like the
authority that can
punish you is
looking it over, then
that means of communication
loses that meaning.
And that was a very--
you know, having--
even for teachers
having email access
wasn't really the same as
having email access here.
INTERVIEWER: I
quite like the story
where you were very keen to
get in to watch "Harry Potter."
And there was an argument
with the teachers
who wanted to show them "The
Chronicles of Narnia" again.
And I liked that the--
perhaps you could
talk about the differences
with the other teachers there
and also why the peoples were so
keen to watch the Harry Potter
film that connected
them to the world.
SUKI KIM: I mean,
it's not-- sorry.
I don't want you
to misunderstand.
It's not like I'm a-- I mean,
I'm not a "Harry Potter" fan.
But my students just did
not have access to anything.
None.
They were not allowed out.
They were not allowed to keep
in touch with their family.
They had nothing.
Basically I'm the
only thing they had,
I realized more
and more and more.
I really felt
motherly towards them.
And they, one by
one, towards the end,
kept asking me about Harry
and Ron and Hermione.
And I was like, did these
kids-- where did you learn this?
And it only is because
in that school,
the textbook was chosen very
carefully that was approved.
But it was an old dated textbook
that was once used in China.
So anything that was used
in China, the North Korean
government let it go.
It was very, very dated.
But you know those ESL
textbooks have little passages.
And in those passages
were so dated,
they would talk about
like, paying for something
with a $2 personal check in
the US, and things like that.
And I would have to
just say, actually,
we don't do that anymore.
But they actually talked
about "Harry Potter" in one
of those textbooks, supposedly.
And because they had so little,
I realized a little information
about the outside
world, they really
soaked it up, like a sponge.
So all of them
knew that there was
this phenomenon outside that
they had no idea about called
"Harry Potter."
The things they knew was
"Harry Potter," JK Rowling,
and what is that?
The sports that they do.
Kiddich or something?
INTERVIEWER: Quidditch, yeah.
SUKI KIM: Quidditch.
Yeah.
Quidditch, and then Harry,
and Ron, and Hermione.
But they would ask
me things like,
so is Quidditch really fun?
And I would be like,
no, I don't play that.
[CHUCKLES] So they were
really keen on this.
And then by chance I found
out one of my colleagues
had-- younger
colleagues, actually,
from England had one of
the Harry Potter movies
on her, like a DVD.
So then I applied to teach
that to the counterparts
because I said it's
mentioned in the textbooks.
In order to finish my
lesson, it's important.
It's detrimental to
my lesson that they
understand what it is.
And then it was actually
miraculously approved,
which I couldn't believe.
So the words just went
around the campus.
They all were so excited.
All day, I would get
like-- every day,
it's like, so when
are we watching
Harry and Hermione and Ron?
And then my colleagues,
the Evangelical fundamental
Christian group-- because there
were degrees in that group.
Some were so much more
Orthodox than others.
So more senior ones
actually came to me
and said this is unacceptable.
It's not going to happen.
Because they said they were
now aiming for "Narnia."
And "Narnia"--
I've never seen it,
but "Narnia" has a very
religious tone to it,
overtone to it.
So they absolutely
forbade me, and they
applied to teach
"Narnia," which then
got rejected by the North
Korean counterparts.
So it was suddenly a
battle between "Narnia"
and "Harry Potter."
And "Narnia," once it got
rejected, I was given a choice.
And the Orthodox group, they
really felt that it was filth.
So I had these crying and crying
moment just arguing with them.
Because I was like, I don't
think Harry Potter is evil.
And they were like, it's filth.
And literally my
heart broke, I think,
because it was so censored.
My kids, they couldn't
have one or the other,
because it was
complete censorship.
They were just not
allowed this information.
And I was given a choice to
show either one or the other.
I taught two groups.
Out of 270 young men, 50
were in my direct charge.
So these are the kids that were
like my babies, 50 of them.
And there were two
groups of them.
And my colleagues, the
fundamentals Evangelicals said,
choose one group.
Then you can show it.
So I was just really-- it was
a horrible choice to make,
because I have to choose
one group of boys.
And I did battle
with that decision,
because I thought, how can I
break their hearts like that?
Because they were
so disappointed.
And I thought, you know, better
show it to one group than none.
That was a choice that had to be
made, like a "Sophie's Choice."
But they did see it.
They marveled at watching it.
And I thought they would
talk about things like the--
because it was the third one,
which is really like, dramatic,
the third installment.
So I thought they would be
more fascinated by that.
But in fact what was amazing
is because I had just been
teaching essay writing to them.
And essay writing,
by the way, was
impossible to teach because
they didn't understand
the whole concept of
coming on with an argument
and proving it with evidence.
That's what essays are about.
And that was impossible there
because critical thinking
is just not allowed.
So we'd been battling with
essay writing so much.
So when we watched
"Harry Potter,"
there's a scene
where Hermione says,
I have to write essays for
Professor Snape's class.
And that's the moment
the boys talked about.
They're like, Hermione has to
write an essay, too, like us.
And I really thought, uh.
This is what the
government is denying them.
Basically it was the connection.
It was the first time I
think they saw a Western film
that they were-- they would only
get allowed things like "March
of Penguins" and "Lion King,"
because those are like a nature
film or the cartoon.
This was a normal--
like people film.
And that's what they latched
onto, was the connection,
I thought.
They really connected
with these kids like them.
And I thought, that's what their
government is denying them--
complete blocking
them from relating
to the rest of the world.
It was a heartbreaking moment.
INTERVIEWER: Do you
want to show some photos
that we've got lined up?
SUKI KIM: Yeah.
I think a lot of them already
got shown somehow from that.
But we can just sort of--
INTERVIEWER: There you go.
And then after that,
we'll take some questions.
SUKI KIM: Yeah.
INTERVIEWER: There's a mic
in the middle to go around.
SUKI KIM: OK.
So that's like in 2002 when
I first arrived in Pyongyang.
And that was actually the
60th birthday celebration
of Kim Jong-il.
So she's holding the sign--
Sun of the 21st Century.
And that's referring
to their great leader,
because great leader's
birthday is the Day of the Sun.
So that's the original
great leader, Kim Jong-il,
who died in 1994.
And his entire
philosophy, Juche,
is what North Korea is based on.
And that's Kim Jong-il
flowers because all
of the great leaders have
flowers invented for them.
So this was Ministry
of Railways display
of Kim Jong-il flowers to
celebrate Kim Jong-il's
60th birthday.
There were hundreds
of these displays.
And I got taken to Kim Jong-il
flower exhibition, where
I was given an explanation
about every single
of those displays, which I think
might sound really fascinating.
But I tell you, after
about like seven or eight,
it's all the same because it's
all about the same flowers
and the same theme.
You see another one like that.
I mean, there were
so many of these.
These are the Workers'
Party leaders.
Back in 2002, when
I went in, I had
to do karaoke with those guys.
[LAUGHTER]
And that was a whole
other experience
which I had to write about for
"New York Review of Books."
INTERVIEWER: What did they sing?
What did you--
SUKI KIM: They were singing
obviously the only theme.
What do you think
their songs were about?
INTERVIEWER: Yeah.
SUKI KIM: Obviously,
the great leader.
I, actually-- the
only song allowed.
I couldn't sing any
American songs, obviously,
no English songs.
I don't know any
North Korean songs.
I could, but that
would have just
seemed weird, for
me to suddenly start
singing North Korean songs.
But the only South
Korean song allowed
was actually a protest song
against the dictator regime
back in 1970s.
And I thought that was
also very fascinating,
songs that was actually
about a different time.
In South Korea, which also had
a dictatorship back in 1970s
against the government,
youth protest song,
now that was used for
propaganda in North Korea
later on, which I
thought was fascinating.
Every mountain you get taken to.
Well, I only got taken
to two mountains,
but they're the most
famous mountains.
And I think this is the case
with the rest of the mountains
there.
Every surface has those Kim
Jong-il stuff carved directly
on the surface of the mountain.
I think in Kumgangsan, which
is South Korea's-- I mean,
the entire Korean peninsula's
most famous mountain has 4,000
such carvings all
across the surface.
So even the nature belongs
to the great leader.
And generally it's saying things
like the great hero, our Kim
Jong-il, and stuff like that.
I mean, it's not really that
complicated what it says.
So that's my kids.
I think they're taking an exam.
That's like a typical classroom.
Yeah, so there
was like a lesson.
That's where the great leaders--
now there are two of them--
that are embalmed.
So you go in there, and
you have to bow to him,
and he's basically
lying there embalmed.
And it's very, very
cold inside, obviously,
because there's a
dead body in there.
That's them watching
"Harry Potter" in my class.
And you can only show, project
a movie very small there,
I realized.
Because there's no
blank space anywhere.
And so those are Kim
Jong-il Kim Il-sung
sayings, whatever they
said, which often like,
our country's the greatest.
It's all stuff like that.
It's not also that complicated.
So in every room, there's
those kind of fame and sayings
by great leaders or
they're portraits.
And you cannot move them.
So if you can't move them,
there is no full blank space
anywhere.
So you have to just
show it half the size
that you either can
watch at a big movie.
So, I mean, we saw that before.
But that walkway, I realized,
as I spent time there,
made sure that there was
no privacy because you
are seen everywhere.
There are windows on
either side of that.
So wherever you
are, you are seen.
So that's my kids, a set of my
kids doing great leader duty.
So there was a
building on campus
that was basically a great
leader, Kim Jong-il-ism study
hall.
So that's where you go and study
the study of the great leader,
and they went there every day
to learn great leader studies.
And six students took
turns to guard it 24/7.
So even if it's like
minus 40 degrees,
you stand outside and
guard the building.
It's an empty building.
And they put on the--
basically the party uniform
in order to guard the building,
because it's a holy duty.
So actually, my last day
there, Kim Jong-il died.
And that was a coincidence.
So I witnessed
the whole reaction
to Kim Jong-il's death.
And that's their only
newspaper announcing
the death of Kim Jong-il,
which I ended up actually
getting a copy of.
INTERVIEWER: As
you were leaving.
SUKI KIM: As I
was leaving, yeah.
INTERVIEWER: Any questions?
As you move to the mic,
I will ask one question.
Do you think that it's a
good thing or a bad thing
that tourism to North
Korea is increasing?
Obviously that's
giving money to the--
SUKI KIM: Tourists.
INTERVIEWER: Tourism, Yeah.
SUKI KIM: I'm against
it, personally.
That's my personal opinion.
I think different engagement
methods are probably necessary.
But tours?
I don't know what
there is to tour about.
I don't know about-- they called
them torture porn or something.
I think there's a term for that,
voyeurism with poverty tours.
And it's a gulag
pretending to be a nation.
And that money the tourists
spend, it might seem curious.
But it's not that curious,
because you get taken
to the exact four, five sites.
And it's just not that funny.
North Korea is literally a
gulag pretending to be a nation.
And every penny you spend there
will go directly to the regime
to suppress and torture
and execute their people.
So I do think actually that
tourist money is not money.
It's bolstering the regime.
INTERVIEWER: OK.
AUDIENCE: I'm really
curious about storytelling.
You mentioned that you showed
"Harry Potter" to them.
And I'm curious about
like-- because you only
showed it to one class.
And I'm wondering, was it
retold to the other class?
And how did that story
kind of propagate, and how
does storytelling generally
work within that kind
of environment?
SUKI KIM: What do you mean?
The storytelling of
whatever happens?
I mean, it's an
important method there.
One of the things actually
they did to amuse themselves,
which seems, really,
you know, they're kind
of too old for it-- 19, 20.
But they did tell stories
to amuse themselves.
They did nothing else.
So they told me in
evenings, they-- there
was a little free
time they gather
to watch their television, which
is all about the great leader.
So I think a lot of
times with the TV on,
they did little games and stuff.
But they said they
would do stories.
They would make like
one is playing a boy.
Like almost like a theater.
But they would tell stories,
like little made-up theater
to entertain themselves.
I mean, it seems so not
2015 kind of an amusement,
but they did do that.
So it is, actually,
I think a way they
do entertain themselves there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Fascinating stuff.
Thanks so much.
I wondered just a bit
more about sort of whether
or not your sense of whether
or not people actually
question anything.
Because you talked
about the fact
that they are totally isolated.
That isn't like some
fake they just don't
know what's going on outside.
But do you get any sense of
that they're actually beginning
to question what's going on?
Like what are they looking for?
For example, when
they couldn't watch
"Harry Potter," that class,
the authorities had said no.
Is that something that
actually upset them
and made them think about it?
Or did they just have total
obedience to their leadership?
SUKI KIM: It is there.
Of course it's there, the
doubt against the regime.
But it is so squashed
that-- you know,
there are different
levels of that.
Number one is actually
something that we didn't finish
talking about, which is lies.
My students lied all the time.
There were different
levels of lies.
One, they lied because
they were always
fearful of-- like the
guard duty, for example.
They would do
those guard duties,
and they would say
they didn't do it,
although I saw them do it.
So it was such a lie
that made no sense.
Or they would say like, I
cloned a rabbit in fifth grade.
And, you know,
just nonsense lies.
But I think they were
regurgitating those lies.
Or sometimes they
lied out of habit.
So this whole lying culture
does make it very difficult
to see what's really going on.
And that's a part of the
whole propaganda thing.
And you constantly have to
pretend to do something else.
It creates a shield,
and you can't really
see what's going on.
So that lying culture made
that really difficult.
But I think the more and
more I was there, I did
think there were
slight questions why.
Because they would ask me.
Of course they could see
that I'm traveling freely.
And they're not.
They're not even
allowed to leave
their-- none of
those kids had ever
been to any of those mountains.
And these are elite.
They've never been to
their country's most famous
mountains, because
they're not allowed.
So I think they
did question that.
But the questions
that-- I mean, I
think this is probably our
best way to think about it.
I think two ways
is probably easiest
to think about that question,
which gets asked most often.
How much do they really know?
I think humanity is not
that different anywhere.
But this is all they've
known and born into.
So even though they might
question for a second,
within that context, I
think if you think of them
as the most abused household.
So if you've basically been
born and bred in endless abuse--
physically, and
emotionally, psychologically
beaten every single
day-- that I think
it is really hard to
fathom what else is there.
So there's that level.
But I think also the
control that they have,
making sure you don't move,
physically, because you're not
allowed to move anywhere.
Make sure you don't share any
information, because you're not
allowed.
And I think that just binds you.
You become helpless.
There's not much you can do.
And I think also the punishment
is so great when there's
a gulag, and there's
public execution,
and also you report
on each other.
So I think that all
those doubts-- I
did see little inklings of it.
But it gets squashed so quickly.
I mean, it's just like there's
not a-- it's like so rapid.
It's a moment of a
flicker, and it's gone.
And I think it's
because punishment is--
and so in answer to that,
I think it's like us.
It's not that different
on some level,
but it's so
tremendously different.
And the punishment is
beyond what we can fathom.
And if you are
living in a gulag,
and one thing you say
wrong would get you
and your family and
everyone you know killed,
then you would probably not
express more than a second.
AUDIENCE: Just another
super quick question,
which may just be a yes or no.
Do you think this regime
will fall in our lifetime?
SUKI KIM: I mean, the world
has been questioning that.
So I don't-- I mean, I cannot--
I don't think that I say that
authoritatively, but having
studied this topic as long as I
could stand it and
having been there,
I've also talked to
all the defectors,
traveled to all of the
surrounding regions.
I mean, I've just been
following it for over a decade.
And I just feel like
that's up to us.
I think I did come to a
conclusion by living in there.
I don't know if it
could come from inside.
You might see little
flickers, but that flicker
gets squashed so quickly.
I think whoever talks about
North Korea's spring compared
to Arab spring or
compared to Cuba
or compared to East Germany,
West Germany, all of that,
I personally think that's
nonsense because we've never
seen anything like this.
A gulag concentration camp
in existence for 70 years?
That's a different
animal altogether.
This goes back to why
backpacking, touring into North
Korea, I'm against it.
So I don't know if it
could fall on its own.
But I do think-- I
find it a little-- I
mean, one of the reasons
for writing this book,
and it is a bit nutty thing
to do to go in there, I think,
undercover.
But I think I just find
it morally unacceptable
that world is there, and
the rest of us are here.
There's something really
deeply disturbing about
that, I think just
humanity in general,
because I think it's horrific.
So I don't know.
I don't think they can
do it on their own,
but I think the world can
maybe make that happen.
I think the first step
is caring about it,
caring about the issue, and then
maybe something will change.
I don't know.
But I think it's up to us.
INTERVIEWER: Thanks a lot.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for being here today.
My question has to do
with academic curriculum.
I wonder if you can expound
a bit about, if you know,
what the average
14-year-old learns.
And the reason I
ask is because it's
been said that knowledge
is power, and all this.
I think if it's a
subject like math, where
it can be taught rotely,
and you learn the facts,
and it never sort of expands
your mind into the world-- one
interpretation.
But something like
literature or economics,
how can you learn those
subjects without thinking
about the world?
And is it done that way?
SUKI KIM: I think that's
another-- because people
do ask me about reunification.
What do I think?
And I think that goes back
to that education thing.
Like where do we begin?
Because what I
saw there was it's
not possible to teach economics
and literature without bringing
the world in there.
So if they have the
basic information--
they were so bright.
I mean, they learned
English so quickly.
They worked so hard.
But their general
knowledge had a gap
that I just could
not understand.
They thought scientists changed
blood type A to B-- North
Korean scientists, of course.
So if you teach that to
students in a science class,
or they learned basketball
makes them grow taller.
So, I mean, it's basically
teaching nonsense.
Because in order to teach
economics or science or any
of these things-- how
can you teach computer
without telling them about
Steve Jobs or Mark Zuckerberg
or the internet or any of it?
So I did not-- and literature,
out of the question.
The only book they are
allowed to learn that is not
North Korean was
"Disappeared with the Wind"--
"Gone with the Wind," which
is about North and South
civil war, where North wins.
There's all reasons why only
that information is allowed.
So, I mean, what
literature do they know?
Only the great
leader's literature.
So I don't think that education
as we know it exists there.
Because their system is
designed in order to uphold
the myth of the great leader.
In order to uphold
that, they need
to make their students dumb.
And that was really
difficult to stomach,
because they were so bright,
they were so sweet, so lovely.
They just did not
know much of anything.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi Suki.
My name is Arvin.
I had a quick question about
the "Harry Potter" movie again.
I was wondering, was parts
of the movie censored?
Because I know it's
a fictional movie,
so I guess that's why it
was allowed, because it kind
of shows a fictional world.
But the beginning
of the movie shows
parts of London, people
taking the train,
and they're living in houses
and interacting with each other.
I was wondering,
were those parts
of the movie
completely censored?
SUKI KIM: No.
Amazingly, the North Korean
staff just let it happen.
Because I think it was
mentioned in the textbook.
So they were just kind of
bureaucrats with that one--
luckily passed it.
And they could have
easily said no.
But I think some of it, I
was thinking at the time--
because it's also
a little mythical.
It's not kind of
real London, is it?
Obviously not.
It's Harry Potter's London.
So I think that's why it was
kind of magic thing made it
better than like a normal
today's London visuals, which
they wouldn't have wanted.
AUDIENCE: One other question.
Was the movie screened
in English or--
SUKI KIM: Yeah, because
they were learning English.
So that was a part
of an English lesson.
AUDIENCE: And I saw on the
picture there was text.
Was that North Korean text
so they could understand,
or were they speaking
fluent English?
SUKI KIM: What do you mean text?
There was--
AUDIENCE: I think on the
picture there was subtitles.
SUKI KIM: The pictures
didn't have subtitles.
I think it was my
writing to explain maybe
in Korean or something.
No, there was no subtitle.
No, they understood the movie.
Their English was very good.
AUDIENCE: And last question.
It might be a more
personal question.
I was wondering, like coming
back to the Western world
and writing this book and
speaking about your experience,
do you ever feel that you're
threatened or exposed?
Like--
SUKI KIM: Me?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SUKI KIM: Well, that was always
a part of the whole thing.
I think obviously being
there was the worst of it.
Consequences were frightening.
So when one side started
following this topic
and deciding to write a
book, that scary part of it,
which I was scared, every
single day, of being there.
And sometime after when
the book was coming out,
I was getting threats.
So it was scary.
AUDIENCE: Where you getting
like emails from the government?
SUKI KIM: I was getting emails
from the head of that school,
who are working with the regime
to absolutely stop publication,
send the manuscript to them.
And it was threatening.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SUKI KIM: Thanks.
INTERVIEWER: Do you regret
that you can't go back?
SUKI KIM: Oh, I'm
not going back, no.
INTERVIEWER: No,
but did you regret
that you can't go back again?
SUKI KIM: No, because I
feel like I poured myself
into-- this whole
project took, I think,
12 years from the beginning.
INTERVIEWER: Wow.
SUKI KIM: And I threw
everything I know
into this book on the topic.
So there isn't really much
more I can say at the moment,
I think.
I got to understand it, I think,
as I possibly humanly could.
So I think if I do go back,
maybe something would have
changed in that
world, or something
in different circumstances,
so I can find different truth.
INTERVIEWER: We'll take--
oh-- these questions,
but make them shorter.
OK.
AUDIENCE: My
question is actually
related to fear as well.
Because presumably,
those kids must
live under such constant fear
all the time and distress.
Did you see it
manifested in any way?
SUKI KIM: Did I see what?
AUDIENCE: Did you
see it manifested?
How did it manifest?
SUKI KIM: The fear,
how did it manifest.
The fears manifested-- the
fears were every second.
The fears-- you know,
I think it's amazing.
Human beings, one of
the most primal feelings
that we can sense is fear.
And I felt that
so strongly there.
So I mean, a very, very moment.
It's in the book.
When they say, what do
you sing when you all
get together to
celebrate birthday,
because that's what they
do, or do storytelling.
And they said, you know,
songs about the great leader.
And one time, one student
said rock and roll.
And the whole table froze.
And that moment
was absolute fear.
Like my heart sank
when he said that.
Because he just looked around
to see who else heard it,
and I looked around.
And I remember just my whole
body-- my feet felt cold.
Because I realized that he could
be punished because of this.
We all changed the
topic instantly.
But it was moments like
that, something so tiny.
But the fear there was palpable.
You could touch it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Suki.
Thank you for your
really fascinating talk.
I just wanted to
ask you, have you
been involved in any
political activism
off the back of
all the attention
that the book is getting?
Because I can
imagine-- I mean, we
talk about the Holocaust
and the Second World War
constantly, even to this day.
And like you mentioned, this
is even greater than that.
It's been going on for 70 years.
And we still talk
about the guilt
about how come we didn't go into
help Poland, Netherlands, all
the Second World War still.
And this is on a
much bigger scale.
So does the book affect
anything politically?
Is there any move into
maybe the UN or the US
or anyone going in there after--
SUKI KIM: I think as my job,
I mean, the best I could do
was vividly deliver that
world in the deepest
way I know how to the world
so the world can feel.
I always said the purpose
was to humanize North Korea.
So through this book,
if people can actually
feel humanly feelings
towards the people there,
25 million people, who
have now become, sadly,
butt of Kim Jong-il jokes,
which are really tiresome.
And so I think that, as
a writer, that's the most
I can do.
And also bring
back-- another one
that I-- you know, the
reason we have North Korea
is because there
was a Korean War.
And the truth about the Korean
War, which the world calls
"forgotten war," and
this forgotten war,
millions of people got
separated and died.
And where it really
began has a lot
to do with actually the
Second World War remapping
of colonial powers,
starting with the UK,
actually, and China
and ultimately
the US and Soviet Union.
And that remapping created
the division of two Koreas.
It's never a civil war.
And how it affected
that decision that
began from the Cairo
Conference, where
it began in 1943,
with remapping,
and how it resulted in
the division of a country.
And that ended up separating
millions of families
and created today's North Korea.
And I thought, you
know, all I can
do is to relate that
in a readable way
so that people begin
thinking about it
and thinking a little
more deeply about why
we have this tragedy today.
And I don't think--
I mean, I don't know.
Like, political
activism, I think
that's for activists to do.
As a writer, all I can
do is write the best book
I know how on the topic.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much again.
Given that your students can be
quite directly linked to you,
even if you try to cover
things up in the book,
it seems that there's
a risk for them.
Do you know if there have
been any consequences
for your students?
SUKI KIM: The consequences
from this book
was something that was
brought up from the beginning,
right away.
It was obviously the
foremost on my mind.
People questioned a
lot the consequences
for it, actually, the
Evangelical Christians
who brought me in.
I mean, clearly that group
works with the government.
So it's not like the
fact they were missionary
was ever a secret.
I didn't out them.
I'm sure it's unpleasant for
them to have the book come out,
because it's made,
probably, things difficult.
But, you know, the
book was worth it.
But it was not going
to sabotage them
in any way that has to do
with real consequences.
I would think probably moneywise
it might have been hard
for them on some level to
have to raise more money
for the regime on some level.
But kids, the students,
was my foremost concern.
They were really like my kids.
And I felt--
everything about them
is blurred and edited
out so that you
can't tell who's who at all.
Apart from that, when
you read the book,
the kids come across
loyal to the regime.
So they're basically
is nothing to fault
them, as an entire group,
which is how they come across.
It was hard to do,
because individually, they
were so adorable.
And as a writer, doing
characterization,
there were just little
habits and little sayings,
little dialogues that happened
there that was just so lovely,
and I wanted to portray
that unique loveability.
But, you know, that had to be
sacrificed so that they become
very blurry, one
group of people,
who are loyal to the regime.
So I think I protected them.
I felt confident with that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: Last question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Suki.
Thank you very
much for your talk.
My question was
regarding something
you wrote at the
beginning of the book,
where you said when you came
to New York from South Korea,
you felt this was not home.
And then you went back
to South Korea for a bit,
and you didn't feel
that was home either.
Did you get some
sense of closure
from having done this
project to yourself?
SUKI KIM: Yes and no, I think.
I think that when
you do lose a home--
and I think that loss is
something that obviously was
a motivation for writing
the book, but also
is a bigger question, even in
the whole history of the two
Koreas.
I think when you do
lose home as a child,
I don't know if you
can get that back.
But I guess through
writing, you look for it.
And that search
is a temporary way
to appease that lost feeling.
But I'm not sure if I
did get the closure.
As far as looking for truth
for injustice of that world,
I think I did get a closure.
Because it was never
satisfying to go--
I did cover the New York
Philharmonic in Pyongyang,
for example.
There was nothing
to write about that
unless I wanted to be a
publicist for North Korea's
regime, which I really
think that's what they want.
All these articles
about North Korea
that comes out after
like a three-day trip
is what I could manage to do.
But I think by living there and
understanding the place deeper,
that closure did happen
through this book.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: Cool.
Please join me in thanking
Suki Kim for coming.
[APPLAUSE]